the governor of the Bank of England says
that the banks saved Britain from
effective insolvency during the early
stages of the coronavirus crisis
speaking exclusively to Sky News Andrew
Bailey said if the bank had not
intervened during the market meltdown
the government would have struggled to
fund itself for the first time in living
memory we basically had a pretty near
meltdown of some of the core financial
markets when he get to I got to
Wednesday afternoon and the markets team
came down here and he altered and you
know it's not good when they turn up on
mass and you know it's not good when
they say we've got to talk and it wasn't
good we were in this state of what I've
said borderline disorderly I mean it was
disorderly in the sense that you know we
looked at volatility and in what was
core market so this is core exchange
rate it's called government bond markets
we were seeing things that were pretty
unprecedented certainly and in recent
times and we were facing in a serious
disorder while Scots business mentor in
King joins me now from the city and in
this is pretty startling stuff from the
governor of the Bank of England
basically saying the nation was close to
going bust well I mean it's been borne
out by events and I don't think anyone
would really seriously disputed Adam if
you look at the extent to which the Bank
of England has been buying in UK
government gills government IO use as
part of its ongoing asset purchase
scheme that really speaks the speaks of
the heart of the matter in fact it's
interesting Adam last week of course
last Thursday the bank increased the
scale of its QE by 100 billions pounds
to 745 billion pounds and interestingly
the amount the extent to which the bank
is actually buying in gilts is is at the
moment exceeding the extent to which the
government is borrowing but it also
speaks really to an issue that is very
very integral to the bank right now
which is the question of the bank's
independence because obviously the
government is borrowing vast amounts of
money to tie the economy through this
pandemic crisis and the aftermath and
the question is really whether there
would be other
of all this guilts issuance out there
were the Bank of England not who ring it
up as part of its asset-purchase scheme
and that has led some former members of
the monetary policy committee such as
andrew sentence to say well this is
really bringing into question the bank's
independence it's an issue very much at
the heart of the bank's integrity taken
very very seriously by Andrew Bailey and
other members of the monetary policy
committee now the other interesting
thing that's happened today the other
very interesting comments from Andrew
Bailey on that subject that he's written
in a comment piece for Bloomberg today
in which he said that he thinks the bank
should actually start unwinding its
asset purchases QE before it starts to
meaningfully raise interest rates again
now this is a significant statement
because it is effectively a reverse of
long-standing Bank of England policy and
certainly the policy under his
predecessor Mark Carney